lots of Hope here because you're down
upon that c-pawn is the extra pawn and
it's starting to roll up the board and
you're kind of stuck the King can't get
out the g7 pawn needs defense so how
would I try to make a draw for black
what's my best chance and I'm struggling
to come up with any sort of play rook d7
acknowledgment about pawn to c5 that
palm will protect that night
keep it planted on be six or maybe seven
probably Weaver case to me yeah Oh a
blind spot the check and there were 64
this is the counter play she needed but
she only was able to accomplish it
because we should you know miss the
check miss she's playing too quickly
oh I'm shocked by that Wow I think that
players when they're playing blitz chess
and it starts turning into bullet they
serve getting so worried about their
clock that they don't realize at thirty
five seconds with a one-second increment
is actually quite a bit of time and now
this game I don't think is winning
objectively anymore even if white cells
the better chances because of this past
pawn what a mess what a mess and I love
the way that Robert you are one of the
few commentators who I've seen
consistently talked about people using
too little time I feel like most most of
us we only focus on the other side and
the reason I like that is because these
are the best players in the world best
female players in the world and it means
that it's logical but look at this wait
this is winning yeah waiting again and
it's because Yvonne didn't have too much
time that's but yeah I think the
discussion is a worthy one to have but
right now yes if you can hide on can be
high on 87 you can yes why come elite
hiding on 87 and maybe she's gonna do
that now yeah that's a nice little
hiding spot it out rook b8 and Queen and
oh my god there's the struggle of the
century wow I did it I did it I oh my
god I said King h7 I love this hiding
spot oh my gosh what that is absolutely
devastating for unyuu Shanina and okay
we need to take a moment we will be
going and breaking a bit but oh my gosh
so what
interesting about this is the black king
would have loved to be on each seven
itself because then there's none of
these you know king isn't getting out of
check and I can keep my rook behind the
pawn
the point is White's threat is if black
does nothing rook to be a check and you
get a queen and that's what happened in
the game but h5 was the most devious
move because it is threatening rook each
six checkmate which you don't think
about because that was not even on your
radar and the best move for white is
rook takes g7 your rook still protects
the pawn now there's no defense the age
six square and your next move is Ritchie
eight and getting that Queen so we just
like rook to e8 so we're t7 and then we
play work to all those same threats are
I'm in the position oh boy what a what a
sad sad sad sad finale for Anakin I mean
just goes to show you always fight you
always look for these little tracks I
mean if it's a mating that honestly I've
never seen anything like that robber and